hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pop goes now we're
gonna get right into it we're gonna
figure out how to beat this but we got a
lot of people that are in our face sorry
for the delay again with PAX West and
preparing for the new tour by the way
the tour ticket sales are underway you
can check that out in the description
below and find if we're coming near your
city it's just mark Blair calm but now I
have to once again re remember
everything that I've now forgotten over
the duration that I have not been
playing this game and then apply to this
game that I don't even know what I'm
doing
red eyes I'm seeing things or did I
crapped on a crap I don't even remember
this call yeah shitty dukes I've already
got this alright alright got it already
got it sorry on her way then camera
Keith that bad boy up take a look out
that window
through a badger in there no okay
alright so long as I got this underway
everything should be okay cuz this isn't
that bad it's pretty bad but not that
bad so you gotta move your weasel
bastard you're gonna move your boot you
a scooch you go scooch way to the art
room come on dudes always scooched
where'd you scooch to oh I don't like
that you're good okay got it got it
there was something under my destined
something touched my foot under my desk
give me a bright spook all right what do
we got
what does am I supposed to be looking
for I completely forgot I've already
missed him I already miss him where'd
you go oh hey badger you better get out
of there where is he where is he Oh
badger what are you doing blue dedushka
I gotcha
alright well if I'm getting panicked no
one there oh hey buddy scuse me
Wow let me just calmly look out that
window what a serene depiction of the
world around me no I missed him didn't
they freak you alright goddamnit phone
was falling down from my I swear to God
foam just started to fall down on my
wall oh this is weird so I'm touch my
foot in some foams coming down I don't
like either of that I'm actually thrown
off right now because I have aah [ __ ]
well he's there still there I he went I
already got part ah ok I'm panicking I'm
panicking I don't need to panic I don't
actually need to panic
five four guys okay all right
it's fine don't panic he's gonna deliver
his doodle-ooh he can deliver a few more
Duda loose before I lose my get him okay
but all that being said I need to check
when he gets back there and manage my
panic stop it's sliding off the wall
it's good it's so weird it's just [ __ ]
this is not a calming situation here
this is not exactly what I was going for
when I said I did when I didn't say
anything that this was gonna be like a
calming scenario but whatever it's still
falling where is he shut down you bent
camera are you in there yet are they in
there no they're not in there yet they
haven't even muha it's going it's gone
it's gone it's gone okay it's not gone
my light god I told you that's my light
down well I guess I'm just like this
from now on okay I get got real spoopy
up in here oh boy well alright daddy
I've just got a deal just got to deal
with it right I just got a deal with it
ah Dickie duck oh they're gone now okay
are they in the vent yet no they're not
in that vent okay
he's going towards the birthday room
it's not like no it's no indication of
where ah [ __ ] oh that birthday room it's
a different angle that's what it is it's
a different angle so that's why it
doesn't make any sense to me then no
then have they moved yet in the
promenade he's going towards oh so that
does give an indication of where he's
going so if I learn what those rooms are
then I will be better off righty-ho
right mijo he's in there keep that up
what are you doing what color are you
doing are you going I missed him
ah no goddamnit he already got it man
he's quick on that printer okay what
color green and boink okay got it
multitasking is my favorite thing
multitasking is my favorite thing okay
where are the girls I don't think
they've made it past there yet have they
are they gonna steal my phone any second
now is he back yet he's going to the
birthday room okay I know the birthday
room is number one shut that easy peasy
you mean easy lemon squeeze me I got
this even though it's really dark and
spooky now I got this everybody's
panicking I'm not panicking going to the
birthday room again Oh for you because I
don't see them in any of those oh how
did you get there that quickly
that was fast e foo okay the art room
knows that the art room I don't know I'm
gonna learn what the art room is real
right now our room yeah that's the art
room why is he already full of arcades
ah I don't know the spookiest episode
yeah all right oh yeah okay then heat
then you move okay you know move yet
they're real slow tonight they are real
slow that's good for me work in my favor
so fast new Badgers were that spewed
idli
also there's that other printing room
that he doesn't go to but that oh did I
miss me oh god damn it oh god damn it
oh damn oh I did Oh Frick Frick Frick
Frick Frick me he's going to the
birthday room okay gotta calm down he's
going back to the birthday room got him
got ya keep that up okay so the the the
basic strategy is he always got to
return to the center first you you got
to get the camera there so you can see
where he's going oh my god damn it how
did I miss you in the vent
Oh Frick that's not good that's not good
at all
welp I'm dead miss them we're there to
take out from with that did they go all
right man I I don't know I get any
better about the things so I should have
this well handled in just a bit if if
the elements of my room don't bother me
Oh Frick I don't know what to do oh [ __ ]
my power I forgot about the weasel
forgot about the weasel okay or the
Badger the Badger and the weasel are
gonna kick my ass now [ __ ] I'm dead oh
where are the ladies I don't really know
now you will kill me I know that is true
yeah I really believe are there you are
okay found you guys have found you okay
well they got a lot of pieces oh I got
you okay got you just in time okay so I
just gotta keep the heat on this one
hopefully hold them in place so he's
going to the birthday room all right now
I got a better now I got a better thing
got a better way of it in camera Heat
okay got a better way I don't know what
he's going to but it probably the side
right room No
left no where's ah it was that one he
just didn't get there yet [ __ ] okay it's
fine fine okay I got this he's gonna
maintain this for five minutes
No Oh almost missed that oh so I've got
I've got a new strategy where if I know
what room is going in to I don't quite
know which room that is I think it might
be this one but if I know which room it
is beforehand I can leave it on that
before I go look and try to get my panic
down it's just one thing to save me just
a small amount of time with he's going
to the birthday room so I switch to the
birthday room and then I flip back and
forth there until I see them heat that
up do you guys hear that I think it's
fine it's totally fine happy birthday ah
not that oh I really [ __ ] it oh I
[ __ ] it up I got the wrong vent oh
[ __ ] I don't know if they're still gonna
be there stay there ladies see there
look hey okay thank you for being very
okay everything's fine my power my power
yellow get out of there who she's what
if I [ __ ] that up there's every
possibility oh god where's oh god damn
did he are to get the piece I think you
already got the piece I wasn't paying
attention
yes he did oh no is that the Loki's very
few okay very few very few pieces so he
can afford
I can afford that one Uchida sure you
bill all right whatever loops you all
right so I just gotta
these guys are these girls come on bring
me another element give me my win give
me my win I earned it I'm a good boy I'm
a good robot I know that I'm a robot I'm
pretty sure I'm a row ah [ __ ] I'm pretty
sure clicked outside the game I thought
was gonna cry
everything there we go I'm good I'm good
I can't imagine how fast
Weasley's gonna be weaseling his way
through town when he's going at full
sprint like that now that thing by my
foot is still there by the way I haven't
forgotten about that I've just been
ignoring it you should I don't know what
it is I think it's another piece of foam
that fell off or something okay Oh what
did you get for me what are we gonna do
in the horror show of horror land
oh hey badger badger badger are you
looking for you gonna look for foxy cuz
I remember where foxy be down in the
dark secrets of this world that I
remember I remember I think I remember
is off to the right right maybe I'm not
ever sent too sure but I think it may be
that's where I was yes
am I gonna find a hook a lost hook amid
the myriad oh oh no this was mangled
there's bits everywhere not sure what
that means
I mean for mangle I think I know what it
mean Oh mangle you dropped your head
your other head I mean so where's foxy
she's the only one that I haven't really
seen in here i'ma go okay All Right see
you
or maybe no these are all the toy ones
that's right mangle is the toy foxy oh
these are all the toys okay well let me
let me rush into a death we're gonna
find out exactly what's going on here
and then we're gonna deal with it wait
yeah for me
give me the Lord Black Rabbit what the
[ __ ] is the black rabbit what is the
black rabbit
I know about that
although the character that smaller
cameo additions based on the restaurant
you were always remain for guys Freddy
fazbear obviously chica the chicken pop
see the Fox was also a bunny radical
body these four characters were huge
Colonel sir
okay so we've got another rogue element
in the mix I have to watch out for this
[ __ ] good what about the black rabbit
it says stop the black rabbit I don't
know what you mean by that
[Music]
[ __ ] Oh
frickin dick mr. Mogae this is falling
apart at the seams
Oh ah you lied to me what does that mean
are you we will kill you okay oh I
forgot about the vent ah Rick oh I have
no idea where they are
oh I have nine to eight apparently oh
you [ __ ]
what'd I do about that what [ __ ] you I'm
gonna look at the window you're gonna
panic you've died something else barely
I'm gonna die to panic here comes a
panic poppy poopy I can't move I can't
see it's cool you're a bye I'll just
wait here
don't mind me I'll be here dying so
anyway that fell apart quickly but I
think I'll be able to handle this I
should be able to beat this in the next
episode I'm pretty sure - all the other
[ __ ] cuz I know it's not five yeah
ever so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think
as always see in the next video bye bye
[Music]